hello everyone and welcome to the
incredible position from the 1958 game
between Bobby Fischer and Samuel
rashewsky from the U.S Championship
official just played Bishop B3 and
rashevsky attacked his Bishop with
Bishop with knights day five and this is
how Fisher punishes him Ponte E5 98 and
now Bishop characters on F7 with check
and here other chefs can pretty much
resign because after King captures in 96
he loses his Queen there's no move you
can make here he did give up his Queen
and Fisher won in some 42 moves but
what's interesting is that if King
captures then Fisher has a beautiful
first Checkmate in six moves G4 King
captures Rook to G1 King H4 Bishop G5
check King H5 Queen to D1 check only
move is the block with the rook and now
Queen captures on F3 uh would have been
Checkmate so there we have it this is
what happened this is how Fisher slayed
the dragon in 10 moves hope you enjoyed
it see you soon